Hello Charles.
>> Hi Michael. How are you doing?
>> I'm doing okay.
>> Good.
>> It's you know, exciting to
be getting to talk about reinforcement learning.
>> Mm. Reinforcement learning. It's my favorite type of learning.
>> Is that true?
>> It is true.
>> Wow. I like machine learning.
>> I like machine learning too. But of all the kinds
of machine learning, reinforcement learning is my favorite kind of learning. So,
let's, how bout, how bout, giving the opportunity for the students
in the class to learn about reinforcement learning by having us tell
them about it.
>> Oh, let's do that. You first.
>> Alright. We're going to build up on the stuff you told us about last time.
>> You mean the fantastic, well defined, and
well formalized stuff that we talked about last time?
>> Yes, it was fantastic and it laid the
groundwork for what I would like to talk about. So
you set up Markov decision processes, and I'm going to
talk about what it means to learn in that context.
>> Excellent.
>> I find it useful to start off by
thinking about a reinforcement learning
API, like application programmer interface.
So what you talked about is, is this box here.
The idea of being able to take a model of
an MDP, which consists of a transition function, T, and
a reward function R. And it goes through some code and,
you know, it comes out and a policy comes out.
Right? And a policy is, is like pi. It maps states
to actions. And that whole activity, what would you call
that? What would you call the, the, the problem of, or
the approach of taking models and turning them into policies?
>> Maybe I'd call them planning.
>> Yeah that's what I, that's, that's what I was hoping you would say.
>> Mmhm.
>> Alright, now we're going to talk about
a different set up here. We're still
interested in spitting out policies, right? Figuring
out how to behave to maximize reward. But
a learner's going to do something different. Instead
of taking a model as input, it's
going to take transitions. It's going to take samples
of, being in some state, taking some action,
observing a reward and observing the state that is
at the other end of that transition. Alright? And
we'll, I put a little star on that to
say well we're going to see a bunch of these transitions.
>> Mm.
>> And using that information we're going to instead
of computing a policy, we're going to learn a policy.
>> I see. So we call that learning?
>> Yeah, or even reinforcement learning.
>> Mm. By the way, what makes it reinforcement learning?
>> That's a question. [LAUGH].
>> It's not a good question,
but it's a question.
>> I was, I was going to say good question, but
I'll, well maybe, maybe there, it's not that it was a
bad question, it's that I don't have a particularly good answer
for it. So, maybe we need another slide to discuss that.
>> Okay.